damn that was intense all right just saw
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 3 yes I
can describe it SiC World War Z without
any machine guns just World War Z with
swords
I took lashes before we get into a
sponsor sure this video is brought to
you once again by Stardust the Stardust
app as a social media app that let you
review movies trailers TV shows for 30
seconds out of time don't just watch the
critics be the critic it's actually a
good tagline guys if you want to use
that I'll only take 10% 20% Matt like at
least no more than 45 percent but click
the link below download the app follow
me at Jeremy Jones on the Stardust app
react to Game of Thrones episodes tag me
in those reactions and not only will
that give you a chance to be featured
here on Game of Thrones reviews I do on
YouTube or through season 8 anyway just
season 2 that'll also enter you for a
chance to win a trip for you and a
friend to go down to Los Angeles
California for the Game of Thrones
series finale viewing party that
Stardust is putting on I'll be at that
party it'll be fun I'll talk about it
more at the end of this video and talk
about how you can spam enter but first
let's talk about Game of Thrones season
8 episode 3 because yeah and there'll be
spoilers in here if you haven't seen
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 3 I'm
gonna talk about some stuff that
happened in it and it will be spoiled
for you you've been warned like I said
it's World War Z with swords right down
to like zombies crawling up each other
up over the wall like at a point I was
like I think dude who reacted in the
start a snap that I featured on last
week's video I think you might have been
right everyone's gonna die
I thought more we're gonna dive and I
thought were gonna die last week the
show has established itself it's like no
people can die
folks can die and since we're not going
off George RR Martin's stuff or george
RR martin was the one he was the
bloodthirsty one right now these riders
know that they have to live up to that
so you're like I don't know maybe
they'll just overcook it and kill
everybody but right from the get-go this
episode sets up the situation they're up
against because Milla Sandra comes and
lights all the swords on fire and the
like don't go off into the distances of
the darkness you just see there's lights
going out and then they're gone and
you're like yeah I'm mmm that doesn't
look good night man fighter of the day
man even had his Sephiroth moment I was
like who else thought of Sephiroth come
on if you didn't and you've never played
Final Fantasy 7 it's as simple as that
for a while though I was like Mills
Sandra what is it you do here she looked
the swords on fire they all got wiped
out she lit the
on fire they got through that I was like
what do you do is she gave re a pep talk
I was like oh oh I blue eyes and you're
gonna kill blue eye oh the Nightman
fighter of the day man that's pretty
open to interpretation has to be so
cryptic my god just say go kill the
night [ __ ] do it white blue eyes
because she could have been like yeah
you do have blue eyes
yeah thanks which yes someone with blue
eyes shouldn't tell someone to kill
someone with blue eyes pluses already
ever seen that guy how did she know he
had blue eyes but a couple of people
went out like champs they went out
protecting people with just how they
wanted to go out Jorah Mormont like if
he went out protecting anyone but
Daenerys that wouldn't be a great dad
for him proof that when you're in the
friend zone you die in the zone and
theon greyjoy he redeemed himself it was
a lost cause like if Theon had killed
night man fighter of the day man I'd
have been like okay kill him but they
killed each other and cool as it stands
Theon Greyjoy just kind of died he was a
level 30 going up against a level 60
boss which is what Jon Snow looks like
when who's going up against the dragon
he was just going behind rocks the
Dragons breathing fire in him he's like
no I was like I've been there I've been
there in raids to feel your pain
I just gamer 101 right there Jon Snow is
a gamer he bit off more than he could
chew he's about to lose his loot right
before Arya snuck up behind Knight man
because she got past all the zombies on
the way the Nightman fighter of the day
man I know that's not his name that's
what I call him and stabbed it was she
did the raid did you notice the rag she
had the knife she had a disadvantage she
had a free hand dropped the knife into
her hand stabbed him ray did the same
thing in the last Jedi but with a
lightsaber in the throne room saying
like the Snoke throne room saying don't
know why that all the last Jedi what a
day to say I mean not saying Ray was the
first one to do it I'm just saying this
what I thought there boys is that like
you know last week everyone had the
theory they were like oh you're gonna
hide in the crypt that's not smart this
guy can raise the dead you're gonna hide
in a room full of dead people I heard
that and I was like that's so obvious
they're not gonna do that they've been
dead for too long right he can't raise
them no you were all right
I didn't even think of it cuz I was like
it's too obvious we all heard horse
hooves
you called horses I called zebras but
this was a great intense episode usually
Game of Thrones is that cerebral
fighting strategy tactics the game of
thrones this was the game of life about
Game of Life I don't mean game of life I
mean trying to live a lot of conflict a
lot of it's risk and I do mean the board
game Ray
a lot of people died a lot of
friendships were broken a lot of tables
got flipped it was [ __ ] Savage I
didn't even get a clear picture of
everyone who survived this thing I guess
I'll find out next week and we'll get
back to King's Landing find out what
they're doing over there I feel like the
battle is not going to rival this we're
not gonna get a battle that's going to
be this intense so I wonder what it'll
be I feel like it'll either be like
someone's gonna take Cersei out with a
bow and arrow or they're gonna get there
and she's gonna be on the throne be like
all my friends left me I guess you kill
me now I don't know all I know is you
had a horde of medieval zombies and
their mystical overlords trying to wipe
out all life from the north that's holed
up in Winterfell dragons breathing fire
on them dragons versus dragons and that
went on for about an hour and a half
because of me an honest with myself if I
really think about it although I enjoyed
the hell out of the episode for
entertainment value it is a tonal shift
like everything was of King's Landing
and the Lannisters and the scheming and
then at a point in Game of Thrones all
attention was like other zombies in the
north they're coming to all resources
and attentions being thrown there and
then do get stabbed and now he
disappears and he's gone without any
real dialogue or build-up with him as a
character it was like all right
attention back to King's Landing now I
just I really need the King's Landing
thing I need the throne the Game of
Thrones to pay off in order for the show
to feel like it paid off in the end so I
very much enjoyed it I'm glad game of
Thrones had an episode like this or
we've seen fighting before we've seen
dragons breathe fire before but you know
the budget went to those episodes so I
enjoyed it what did you think here are
some Stardust reactions of people who
had some thoughts the action was awesome
battle was fantastic that was a battle
for the ages
look like they was gonna lose I'm not
there saying I wanted a bunch of
characters to die but I think everyone's
expecting a ton of major characters to
really bite the bite the dust on this
one and we didn't really get that but I
just gotta say one that felt like a
personal attack on me I lost some people
that cared a lot about this once were
you Theon Lyanna Mormont dies and that
was like oh my god she can hear her
bones cracking everyone's dying Jorah
dies one of the dragons might have died
I'm holding in silence and sorrow we got
some characters died that we've been
attached to since season one so there
was the stakes and the night king is
finally defeated now it's on desert see
didn't I
King was supposed to be this big threat
and it just feels like he kind of went
out like a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
are you completely saved at the tape
what can I say this is a great weekend
for starts in game now this holy
[ __ ] know what I think now you know
what they think and thank you once again
to start us for sponsoring this episode
in every episode of Game of Thrones I'm
doing for season eight remember to click
the link below download the Stardust app
follow me at Jeremy John's and that'll
enter you for a chance to be featured
here in my Game of Thrones videos like
you just saw and will also enter you for
a chance to win a trip for you and a
friend to go to Los Angeles California
for the Game of Thrones series finale
party that the folks that start us to
putting on well I'll be there well I'll
be watching the Game of Thrones finale
laughing crying speculating and then
wanted me to tell you this so I'm
relaying the message react to Game of
Thrones episodes any and all Game of
Thrones episodes you react to if you
tagged me at Jeremy Jones on the
Stardust app every reaction you tagged
me in will be a new entry for you to win
well it works for Game of Thrones
episodes want to make that clear but
still there's like 70 of those yes in
the video game world we call that
spamming but that's how they're doing it
so have fun spamming it improves your
odds of winning and next week in my Game
of Thrones Season eight episode 4 video
I'm gonna announce the first winner who
won a trip for them and a friend to go
down to Los Angeles California for the
Game of Thrones series finale so stay
tuned for that be sure to watch
especially if you enter I mean watch
anyway but if you enter definitely watch
alright so Game of Thrones season 8
episode 3 but I am calling World War Z
with swords have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you'd like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]